[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
kochwelt ich mache heute ein leckeres
pfälzisches gericht denn heute gibt es
bei uns zu hause dampfnudeln und ich
werde jetzt gleich noch eine kartoffel
super doch so machen aber die
kartoffelsuppe bekommt ihr einfach in
einem separaten video heute gibt es hier
dampfnudeln und dann mache ich noch eine
leckere vanillesoße mit dazu und ihr
braucht auch gar nicht viele zutaten
dazu dampfnudeln sind wirklich sehr
einfach zu machen man muss nun so ein
paar tipps beachten und die verrate ich
euch heute und zeigt euch jetzt hier
kurz die zutaten wurde wahr gemacht sind
ganz kurz die diskussion darf nun sind
schwäbisch ich weiß es wird immer
gestritten ob sie verletzt sind oder
bayrisch aber die sind schwer mich dass
ich wenn du zu mir sagt stressig pfälzer
richtig so als würde ich mir mit anlauf
jetzt muss ich sagen voll in die fresse
hauen dampfnudeln schwäbisch melasse
morath im recht aber dass du nicht fällt
sich deswegen zeige ich euch jetzt die
zutaten wir brauchen 75 einen würfel
hefe 400 milliliter milch dieser ganz
leicht lauwarm
ein teelöffel zucker und teelöffel salz
hier habe ich noch 70 gramm wasser das
ist auch lauwarm und 40 gramm butter
dankes an mir bislang hat das lauwarme
mit der darf nur lauwarm 200 heiß und
natürlich komme dampfnudeln aus der
quali auch kennenlernen vor allem die
kaffee man ja und deswegen muss ich mich
richtig anstrengen damit ich den hohen
ansprüchen gerecht werden
ich lese hier meine hilfe in der im
wasser auf und gibt jetzt den zucker mit
dazu dann hat mich jetzt so offenen
konzept gebracht hat erzählt hat was ich
immer ich guck vor gut momentan aber
egal
[Musik]
das ist mir egal kann nicht alles aus
dem schwabenland
aber es ist auch ok morath ein bisschen
hinterher multikulti ich bin ja bad noch
in moralisch farbe und form ihrer
spielerinnen als ich das ein rezept für
dich mannschaft genau jetzt geben wir
die hefe wasser zucker mischung einfach
in die küchenmaschine ihr könnt den teig
natürlich auch mit hand verkneten
man hat halt ein bisschen länger als
spitzel anstrengender aber funktioniert
genauso gut die schlüssel spüre ich
jetzt mit dem mit der milch aus ja
einfach ausgespült und jetzt gebe ich
hier noch mal rein und auch die butter
weil ich habe ja schon hefe mit wasser
verrührt das heißt mutter kann jetzt mit
dazu weil die hämischen assist und dann
lasse ich das einfach kurz verkneten
und gebt dann immer wieder mehr dazu
[Musik]
mein tag wurde 15 minuten lang geknetet
und ich habe das mit dem knethaken
gemacht mit diesen captain hook aken und
es müsste auf jeden fall immer mit so
einem knethaken machen weil einfach
hilfe tagen sehr schwerer tag ist also
egal ob jetzt ein kennwort mit
kitchenette oder irgend eine andere
maschine habt immer knethaken ja und
jetzt klebt auch der teig gar nicht mehr
das heißt wenn man den so lang knetet
dann klebt es nicht mehr um nicht kann
ihn einfach ohne mehl weiterverarbeiten
denn ich muss ihn jetzt erstmal aufgehen
lassen und die schwäbische hausfrau dies
mit der hand noch macht wie lange muss
ich okay du hast schon gegeben damit
auch gebrachte zu suchen
das sind richtig schön zusammen fester
teil sehr geschmeidigen teig und wenn
man so ein hefeteig lange knetet wird er
einfach super locker und vor allem wie
gesagt gebt damit dem gebe ich mir jetzt
zurück in die schüssel und lasst den ich
erst mal komplett aufgeben also mal seht
ihr jetzt eine relativ kleine kugel und
gleich aber eine grosse kugel und ich
nutze jetzt gleich die zeit und bereits
schon meine suppe vor und der teig geht
jetzt etwa eine stunde auf halbe stunde
für stunde bis er sich verdoppelt hat
dann sehen wir uns gleich jeder und
machen dann auch gleich die weissrussen
zusammen mein tag ist jetzt aufgegangen
und ich habe hier schon mal eine suppe
aufgesetzt und guck mal wie groß der
teig geworden ist also riesengroß und
den können jetzt weiter verarbeiten und
zwar werde ich aus dem jetzt etwa 15 bis
16 dampfnudeln formen deswegen wenn ihr
eine kleine familie zeit oder einfach
eine kleine portion machen wollt müsst
dann halt echt die hälfte davon nehmen
als die hälfte des rezepts passt bei mir
in eine pfanne rein und so wie ich jetzt
heute mit dem doppelten rezept muss ich
einfach das ganze auf zweifel
teilen hat er jetzt muss ich das kurz
abwägen
nein gar nicht jetzt wiege ich mir die
stückchen ab und zwar haben die alle so
etwa um die 90 gramm
das ist für mich so die perfekte größe
für dich auch ja
[Musik]
also ich hab jetzt genau 14 stück
gestern war es nämlich bei der hälfte
des rezepts 7 und die passenden richtig
gut in eine pfanne und jetzt werde ich
daraus runde kugeln formen und die
müssen dann noch mal auf gehen und zwar
müsste bei den kugeln einfach beachten
ihr nehmt euch das teilstück formt mit
den fingern von außen nach innen
und dann waren wir das ganze zu einer
kugel
[Musik]
und jetzt gebe ich mich hier auf meine
stilikone mattes ein bisschen mehl damit
ich später beim anheben
einfach das beste weg kriege ohne jetzt
die dampfnudeln dann zu beschädigen
und nachdem ich das jetzt hier gemacht
habe müssen die dampfnudeln abgedeckt
noch mal ungefähr 20 minuten aufgehen
aber die zeit nutzen willst gleich um
uns vanillesoße herzustellen
[Musik]
die kugeln denke ich jetzt mit
frischhaltefolie ab ihr könnt das ganze
auch mit einem küchentuch machen aber
die dampfnudel die dürfen hat das
einfach nicht austrocknen zum scheißen
wir uns später nämlich auf deswegen
nehme ich da am liebsten in
frischhaltefolie könnte er auch später
noch mal weiter verwenden den gewählten
strecke super und es dass ich jetzt hier
abgedeckt und richte kurz meine zutaten
für die vanille sauce und die zeit nicht
vergleichen für die vanillesoße brauche
ich drei 150 milliliter vollmilch ihr
könnt auch gern ein teil durch sahne
ersetzen wenn ihr wollt fünf esslöffel
zucker 3 gelbe ein teelöffel stärke und
so speisestärke eine prise salz und ich
nehme meinen vanilleschote extrakt wenn
ihr das nicht habt könnte auch einfach
eine vanilleschote nehmen und da das mag
auskratzen
und das geht jetzt ziemlich einfach ich
nehme jetzt einfach meine milch und gebt
ihnen kleiner topf und verrührt hier
einfach kurz die stärke mit dem mit der
restlichen milch also so ein paar es
leute habe ich jetzt aufgehoben
er braucht damit ist das wetter katrin
kann ohne dass es hat xing gibt da auch
meine drei eigelbe rein
die abstimmung hat ich bin darüber
und wenn ihr das dann alles verrührt hat
kommt es mit in den topf der top ist
noch nicht an
ich möchte nämlich erst alles
miteinander verrühren dann auch direkt
er zucker wenn ihr es etwas süßes oder
weniger süß haben wollt einfach mehr
oder weniger benutzen
nein cellini mir nicht viele frauen über
die super aber das ist jetzt vanillesoße
und so erhält nur übrigens auch so diese
typisch gelbe vanillesoße den weigeldt
mit drin wenn man jetzt vanillesoße aus
dem päckchen nimmt also aus einer tüte
sind die auch immer gelb aber da ist
einfach farbstoff du darfst entdecke
jetzt öffnen
und ich habe auch schon mal gezeigt wie
man eine vegane vanillesoße machen kann
da könnte einfach mal auf einem kanal
auf seine stoppen welt vorbeischauen und
euch das rezept anschauen und jetzt gehe
ich hier vanillemark mit rein und da
kommen jetzt schon so etwa und teelöffel
dazu gebe nichts was sehr hoch
konzentriert aber das soll ja auch
richtig intensiv nach vanille schmecken
richtig lecker geld nicht gut
und jetzt scheint sich hier den herd auf
mittlerer stufe und rühre während dem
aufkochen immer und schau einfach dass
das ganze eine schöne stück flüssige
konsistenz hat müsste halt echt dabei
stehen bleiben oder zuzuhören
[Musik]
eine soße ist jetzt ein gedicht und sie
ist jetzt ganz kurz wie man hier sieht
man sind die koch trotz ein bisschen auf
und es reicht auch schon werden das
ganze ist ja kein vanillepudding sondern
eine vanillesoße
und ich möchte jetzt lassen sie muss
auch nicht zu dick wird deswegen nehme
ich jetzt schon vom herunter und steckt
sie an der oberfläche direkt mit
frischhaltefolie ab damit sich jetzt
auch keine haut bildet ich muss jetzt
leider noch auf meine buchteln wurde
schon sein auf meine dampfnudeln warten
die sie noch nicht komplett aufgegangen
das kann wie gesagt einfach bisschen
länger dauern als 20 minuten
und ich warte jetzt noch mal so zehn
minuten und dann bereite ich hier gleich
alles vor zum fertigmachen meine
dampfnudeln sind jetzt inzwischen auch
so ein bisschen aufgegangen und jetzt
kann ich sie in die pfanne geben
dafür gebe ich jetzt drei esslöffeln
wasser und ich sagen drei esslöffel öl
in die pfanne ich nehme jetzt
geschmacksneutrale sonnenblumenöl dann
kommt da ein halber teelöffel salz mit
rein
vielmehr würde ich auch ebenfalls in
echt zu salzig wird und 130 bis etwa 150
milliliter wasser kommt jetzt einfach
drauf an wie groß eure pfanne ist und
ganz wichtig bei einer pfanne also die
muss erstens tief sein meint schon fast
zu flach aber es geht ich habe gestern
auch noch ausprobiert und der deckel
muss einfach richtig dicht schließen bei
mir schneider das problem ein deckel
schließt nicht ganz dicht deswegen habe
ich jetzt hier 150 milliliter wasser
weil einfach ein bisschen auch an die
umgebung verdunstet und jetzt lasse ich
das hier kurz aufkochen und dann setze
ich etwas 7 genau sieben stück passen 63
7 dampf not und rein muss das ganze also
auch zwei portionen machen aber das ist
kein problem denn ich kann dir einfach
warm stellen zu lang
[Musik]
jetzt kocht das wasser jetzt kann ich
hier die dampfnudeln anheben und damit
rein geben das mache ich jetzt ziemlich
schnell eins in der mitte sechs stück
außenrum je nachdem wie groß europa
neben es passender mehr oder weniger
rein und ich hab das jetzt kurz bisschen
runter geschaltet einfach damit ich mir
jetzt die finger beim reinsetzen nicht
verbrenne
aber ich schaltete sofort wieder hoch
[Musik]
jetzt gebe ich den deckel wieder drauf
los aber erst ganz kurz aufkochen und
jetzt gebe ich den deckel drauf guckt
dass er eben wie gesagt ganz dicht drauf
sitzt jetzt ist wirklich ganz wichtig
dass wir den deckel jetzt nicht mehr
unternehmen denn wenn ihr das jetzt
macht dann fallen euch die dampfnudeln
zusammen und sind eben nicht so schön
fluffig und ich warte jetzt einfach ganz
kurz bis das wasser richtig kocht und da
richtig dampf drin entsteht denn dann
schalte ich auf die halbe stufe runter
also auf mittlerer stufe
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich auch mittlere stufe und
bei mir sieht man jetzt auch deutlich da
kommt überall so ein bisschen dampf raus
also das ist eigentlich nicht so gut
aber sehr gelingen mir trotzdem also
zumindest sie gestern gelungen
und jetzt warten wir einfach das dauerte
ungefähr 20 minuten dann ist das
komplette wasser verdampft die
dampfnudeln finnland durch und dann
bietet sich und die kruste und wenn
jetzt kein glasdeckel habt und mit
durchgucken könnt und ich sehe wenn das
wasser weg ist dann könnte einfach
hinterher denn dann fängt es einfach ein
bisschen zu braten
[Musik]
meine dampfnudel sind jetzt gleich
fertig als man hört so ein bisschen das
knistern hat schon angefangen und jetzt
seht ihr hier das sich am deckel immer
ganz viel von diesem kondenswasser
bildet jetzt gibts da beträgt damit ist
dann auch die dampfnudel und runter
tropft und zwar schwenken wir jetzt die
pfanne einmal rüber
entweder hat frau sollte bei mir hat es
läuft einfach unten nochmal in den boden
aber ich will einfach nicht dass es auf
die dampfnudeln tropfen das drückt es
die dann so ein bisschen ein jetzt ab
dem zeitpunkt kann ich jetzt noch zwei
minuten warten dann bildet sich nämlich
unten die kruste und dann sind die
dampfnudeln gleiche fertig ich streiche
jetzt schon mal meine vanillesoße durch
einen sie denn es kann sein dass da
einfach so vom ein paar stückchen mit
drin sind und sagt man da einfach keine
klümpchen mit drin
und ich mag es gern wenn die sauce nicht
zu fest ist deswegen habe ich vorhin
auch nur einen teelöffel stärkeren
gegeben
wenn ihr aber wohl dass sie etwas fester
ist im kalten zustand müsste einfach nur
unbedingt stärken treiben geben
[Musik]
meine dampfnudeln sind jetzt fertig beim
deckel auf 10 müsst ihr aufpassen das
ist einfach schnell runter zählt damit
einfach kein wasser runter tropft
jetzt gucken wir mal ob die kruste und
schön ist
man hört sie schon so ein bisschen
anfassen als wir heiß ist aber hier
sieht man einfach diese salzkruste
übrigens gibt es die dampfnudeln auch
mit süßer karamell kruste habe ich
selber noch nie ausprobiert aber ich
glaube das wäre auf so nix für mich weil
ich einfach dieses salz großes thema
[Musik]
wollen jetzt gebe ich hier noch die
vanille sauce damit dazu carina willst
du oben drauf oder nebendran nur halb
halb ist so
ich glaube jeder der jetzt vom
bildschirm sitzt will da einfach rein
weiß ordentlich viel vanillesoße
und dann kann das hier schon serviert
werden so und weil ich jetzt den teller
erschlossen stehen lassen wie zeige ich
euch hier einfach wie so eine dampfnudel
im inneren aussieht und wer probieren
sie auch gleich zusammen
[Musik]
ich hatte mal
jetzt durchschneiden ist natürlich
bitter zusammengedrückt eigentlich
reicht muss er einfach mit der gabel
auseinander und die ich bin sehr schön
locker
wobei meine gestern bisschen lockerer
waren aber das macht nichts schmecken
tun sie trotzdem hab ich die salzkruste
hier unten vor allem mit dieser salz
busse sind sie sehr lecker und soll und
definitiv mal nach gemacht werden ich
werde euch jetzt gleich ein foto
schießen freue mich auch über fotos die
er dazu sendet auf facebook oder
instagram und das rezept gibt es zum
nachlesen aufstiegs blog.de und wir
sehen uns einfach beim nächsten mal
wieder
[Musik]
[Applaus]